♪♪
Narrator:
THE HEADS OF THESE GOLF CLUBS
ARE MADE FROM AEROSPACE-GRADE
STAINLESS STEEL.
TO PRODUCE THEM,
THE FACTORY BEGINS WITH
A WAX REPLICA OF THE CLUBHEAD.
TO MAKE THIS WAX PATTERN,
AS IT'S CALLED,
THEY INJECT HOT WAX INTO A MOLD.
THEY EXTRACT THE PATTERN
AND SNIP OFF THE BULK
OF THE EXCESS WAX.
USING HOT WAX AS AN ADHESIVE,
A ROBOT JOINS SEVERAL PATTERNS
TO OTHER WAX PARTS
IN THE SHAPE OF GATES
AND RUNNERS,
THE TERM FOR THE CHANNELS
THAT GUIDE MOLTEN METAL
INTO THE CASTING MOLD.
THEN THE ROBOT DIPS
THESE PATTERNS
INTO LIQUID CERAMIC MATERIAL
FOUR TIMES,
WITH A SHOWER OF SILICA SAND
IN BETWEEN EACH COAT.
THE CERAMIC AND SAND HARDEN,
FORMING A SHELL
AROUND THE WAX PATTERNS.
THEN THE FACTORY
MELTS OUT THE WAX.
THE SHELL IS NOW A MOLD
WITH WHICH TO CAST
THE METAL CLUBHEADS.
ON THE CASTING FLOOR,
A FURNACE HEATS STEEL BARS
TO 3,000 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT --
WELL BEYOND THE MELTING POINT.
THE POURING TECHNIQUE
IS CRITICAL.
THE METAL MUST FLOW
AT A CONSISTENT RATE
TO PREVENT THE FORMATION
OF AIR BUBBLES.
AFTER FIVE HOURS,
A PNEUMATIC HAMMER
BREAKS APART THE MOLD.
WORKERS SAW OFF THE GATES
AND RUNNERS,
SEPARATING THE CLUBHEADS.
THEN THEY GRIND OFF
THE LAST REMNANTS
OF THE GATES AND RUNNERS.
A TURNTABLE RUNS THE CLUBHEADS
THROUGH A SANDBLASTER,
WHICH GIVES THE METAL
A PARTICULAR FINISH.
NEXT, THEY STICK ON
A METAL BADGE
BEARING THE CLUB'S MODEL NAME.
THEY APPLY
A DOT OF AUTOMOTIVE PAINT.
THE COLOR IDENTIFIES
THE ANGLE OF THE CLUB.
THERE ARE 12 DIFFERENT ANGLES.
NOW THEY LINE THE NECK
OF THE CLUBHEAD WITH EPOXY,
THEN COAT THE END OF THE SHAFT
WITH EPOXY
AND SLIP IT INTO THE NECK.
A PNEUMATIC HAMMER PUSHES THE
SHAFT IN AS FAR AS IT CAN GO.
THE SHAFT IS MADE OF EITHER
EXTRUDED STEEL OR CARBON FIBER.
NOW IT'S TIME
TO WORK ON THE SHAFT.
FIRST, THEY CUT IT
TO THE RIGHT LENGTH,
DEPENDING ON THE MODEL.
THEN THEY PUT THE SHAFT
ON A SPINDLE
AND WRAP THE TOP 10 INCHES
IN DOUBLE-SIDED TAPE
TO HOLD THE CLUB'S RUBBER GRIP.
THEY LUBRICATE THE TAPE
AND THE INSIDE OF THE GRIP
BEFORE SLIDING THE GRIP
OVER THE SHAFT.
A LASER LINE HELPS THEM ALIGN
THE GRIP IN THE RIGHT POSITION.
THIS IS CRITICAL, BECAUSE
THE GRIP IS THE GOLFER'S GUIDE
TO CORRECT HAND POSITIONING,
WHICH IS ESSENTIAL
TO A GOOD SWING.
NEXT, A COMPUTER READS THE LIE,
THE TERM FOR THE CLUBHEAD'S
ANGLE RELATIVE TO THE GROUND.
THEN IT READS THE LOFT --
THE TERM FOR THE ANGLE
OF THE CLUBHEAD'S FACE.
THE COMPUTER THEN TELLS
THE TECHNICIAN
WHAT ADJUSTMENTS TO MAKE.
ONCE HE'S MADE THE ADJUSTMENTS,
THE COMPUTER REANALYZES
THE NEW LOFT AND LIE
TO ENSURE THEY'RE PERFECT.
IT'S THIS TYPE OF PRECISION
THAT ENSURE THESE GOLF CLUBS
FIT THE QUALITY SPECIFICATIONS
TO A "T." [tee]